deuxième édition d'un colloque pour
parler de l'autonomie les premières lois
sur la prise en charge de la perte
d'autonomie en france date de 1962 avec
l'instauration des aides à domicile
cinquante ans plus tard quel bilan
dresser et bien cet universitaire n'a
pas la langue de bois
effectivement il ya ce rapport l'europe
de 62 qui dit les gens veulent rester
chez eux
faut les y aider et la cour des comptes
en 2005 10 est grosso modo en 40 ans on
a fait des choses mais aucun
gouvernement quel qu'il soit n'a été
jusqu'au bout
le courage c'est mettre un peu plus
d'argent notamment sur les services à
domicile
on sait que les gens veulent rester chez
eux donc on sait aujourd'hui que
l'essentiel du travail est fait par les
familles
beaucoup trop bernard ennuyer pointe
également du doigt les manques de
cohérence entre les différents
dispositifs à saint-quentin-en-yvelines
l'exemple pourrait venir de gier
handicap
un groupement de coopération qui
intervient dans le domaine de la
gérontologie et du handicap
c'est lui qui est à l'origine de ce
colloque ça va dans la bonne direction
bien plus que dans d'autres départements
donc je peux dire que je vis ici avec
plaisir la perte d'autonomie ne se
limite pas aux personnes âgées des
salariés peuvent également être
concernés autre exemple de mise en
commun le réseau yvelines santé travail
nous avons des équipes qui sont des
équipes pluridisciplinaires puisque
souvent il ya plusieurs ou couto surtout
plusieurs types de problèmes
il ya un air de normes et un juriste un
psychologue et une assistante sociale
nous appliquons une méthodologie qui est
reconnue nationalement
cette année yvelines santé travail à
traiter 600 dossiers et 80 % des
salariés ont été maintenus en emploi en
matière de perte d'autonomie le meilleur
conseil est de prendre contact avec la
coordination gérontologique de son
territoire un projet de loi sur cette
question pourrait être présenté en 2014
par la ministre de la santé